IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU FOR
BEING UP EARLY OR LATE ON YOUR
END AND ON WHICHEVER ONE IT IS.
THERE ARE EVEN MORE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT MAINSTREAM
DEMOCRATS ABOUT WHETHER THERE IS
ANY WAY TO STOP DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS FROM
SECURING THE PARTY’S
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION.
SANDERS BURIED THE COMPETITION
IN NEVADA CAUCUSES SATURDAY, AND
HE IS THREATENING TO UPSET
JOE BIDEN IN THE STATE THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT HAS CALLED
HIS FIREWALL.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM CHARLESTON,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> MORE THAN 12,000 TEXANS
TURNED OUT TO SEE BERNIE SANDERS
IN AUSTIN LAST NIGHT.
>> MY GOD THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE!
>> SANDERS IS STARTING TO SHINE
A LIGHT ON WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
>> IT’S UNFAIR TO SIMPLY SAY
EVERYTHING IS BAD.
WHEN FIDEL CASTRO CAME INTO
OFFICE, HE HAD A MASSIVE
LITERACY PROGRAM.
IS THAT A BAD THING?
EVEN THOUGH FIDEL CASTRO DID IT?
>> HE LEAVES BY DOUBLE DIGITS
AHEAD OF JOE BIDEN,
ELIZABETH WARREN, AND MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG.
>> THAT IS WHAT THE PARTY WILL
DECIDE.
>> BIDEN IS STILL CONFIDENT
AFTER FINISHING FOURTH, FIFTH,
AND SECOND SO FAR.
>> I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
BERNIE AND ME GOING INTO SUPER
TUESDAY.
>> SOUTH CAROLINA, WHERE A
RECENT POLL FOUND BIDEN LEADING
SANDERS AND TOM STEYER AND
THIRD.
>> I DON’T THINK ANYBODY OWNS
SOUTH CAROLINA OR ANYBODY ELSE,
YOU HAVE TO EARN THE VOTES.
>> SOUTH CAROLINA MOST PROMINENT
ELECTED DEMOCRAT IS PREPARING TO
ENDORSE BIDEN AHEAD OF THE
CONTEST.
>> SOUTH CAROLINA IS YOUR
FIREWALL.
>> YOU SAID IT’S MY FIREWALL, I
HAVE NEVER SAID THAT.
>> HE DID SAY IT THOUGH.
>> I THINK I HAVE A REAL
FIREWALL IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> PETE BUTTIGIEG IS HOPING TO
RECAPTURE SOME OF THE MAGIC THAT
HELPED HIM WIN IOWA.
>> NO MATTER WHO YOU SUPPORT, I
SUPPORT YOU.
>> AND AMY KLOBUCHAR HAS NO PLAN
TO DROP OUT.
>> WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
VOTES, I AM THE THIRD HIGHEST
VOTE-GETTER.
>> THE HIGHEST VOTE-GETTER IS A
SANDERS, HE IS SOAKING IT ALL UP
UP.
>> WELL YOU KNOW, I AM A U.S.
SENATOR AND I HAVE A BIG EGO AND
I APPRECIATE THE "BURNING."
BUT IT ISN’T BERNIE, IT’S US.
>> THIS IS AN OPEN PRIMARY,
WHICH MEANS REPUBLICANS CAN GO
AND VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS ON
SATURDAY IF THEY WANT TO.
I JUST SPOKE TO A VERY
REPUBLICAN OPERATIVE HERE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA WHO SAID THAT
THERE IS NO ORGANIZED EFFORT TO
TRY TO GET REPUBLICANS TO VOTE